bail has been denied for a driver
accused of being involved in a deadly
reckless driving incident that happened
over the weekend
clark county prosecutors say that
rodrigo cruz was driving a van on
hollywood boulevard near sahara on
sunday
while a passenger inside that van
allegedly reached
out of the window and then pushed
michelle weisman off her bike
both of them were killed the arrest
report claims that cruz didn't stop
because he was on parole he does have
another hearing next month
well the passenger in that van accused
of pushing and killing the rider is
identified as 20-year-old
giovanni medina barajas now police say
medina barajas fell from the moving van
and he died
and kristen drummond shows us how his
actions are concerning the cyclist
community who already worry about
drivers on the road
the dangers of sharing the road i've had
a lot of motorists who
have behaved very aggressively with
their vehicle
alan snell is an active bicyclist not
only riding in las vegas but
across the country i've had people throw
items at me
and i've definitely had people
buzz me and come i think dangerously
close to hitting me
a concern for him and the cycling
community especially now
after an attack on a bicyclist sunday
morning police say a minivan passenger
leaning out the window intentionally
pushed 56-year-old michelle weisman
off her bike no one less than a [ __ ]
and a mean-spirited person
extending their body and hitting a
bicyclist to cause
harm a police report states evidence
shows the van driver was
also in the bike lane cyclists
constantly have to worry
about about motorists when they're out
on the road
keely brooks is president of the
southern nevada bicycle coalition
the non-profit advocates for cyclists
and their safety
she says this situation serves as a
reminder about the state law
drivers must pass with at least three
feet of clearance between the car
and bicycle there has to be actual
consequences for
motorists when they actually break that
law all you need is
one mean-spirited horrible individual
like this person to
end your life but snell won't let the
situation stop
him from peddling the medal down the
road kristen drummond 8 news now
michelle wiseman worked at the cannery
hotel and casino colleagues and family
are honoring her life with a vigil that
is for tomorrow
at 4 p.m on sahara and hollywood
boulevard